ACCIDENTAL VIDEOS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THIS IS BASED ON THE
PHENOMENON OF SOMETHING
THAT'S ONLY RECENTLY ADDED
TO OUR CULTURE, WHICH IS
WHERE YOU ARE TRYING TO TAKE
A PHOTO OF SOMEONE AND YOU
REALIZE IT'S ON VIDEO AND THEN
EVERYONE IS JUST KIND OF
STANDING THERE REALLY AWKWARDLY.
AND YOU'RE LIKE, "WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?"
LIKE, "OH, IT WAS ON VIDEO."
BUT THEN THEY'VE TRAPPED YOUR
REALLY HORRIBLE MOMENT SO
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THIS GAME IS BUILT AROUND SO I'M
GOING TO SHOW YOU A SERIES OF
ACCIDENTAL VIDEOS.
YOU RING IN WITH THE POSER'S
INNER MONOLOGUE, ALL RIGHT?
IF IT'S FUNNY, POINTS.
LET'S START, FIRST ONE.
THESE TWO PAINT FACE CLUBBERS.
(LAUGHTER)
YES, TOM LENNON.
>> HOW LONG BEFORE SHE
NOTICES I'VE HAD A STROKE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
NEXT ONE.
THESE WELL REHEARSED WILD
AND CRAZY GUYS.
♪
(LAUGHTER)
THE THING ABOUT WATCHING
A LOT OF THESE VIDEOS AT
ONCE IS THAT YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE IN A WEIRD NIGHTMARE
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS SORT OF
MOVING, BUT NOT REALLY.
TOM LENNON?
>> IT'S LONELY ON THE NIGHT'S
WATCH.
>> Chris: NICE, GOOD REFERENCE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
APRIL?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY THE GUY
ON THE LEFT IS LIKE, "HURRY UP,
I NEED TO MAKE THIS MY NEW
PROFILE PICTURE FOR GRINDER."
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> GIRLS?
NO, THANKS, WE'RE CHRISTIAN.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, THESE TWO
FUTURE LEADERS OF THE FREE
WORLD, HOW ABOUT THESE GUYS?
(LAUGHTER)
APRIL?
>> HURRY UP.
ANY LONGER AND MY CHEEK BONES
ARE GOING TO CUT THIS GIRL
TO SHREDS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT, YEAH, FOR SURE.
>> I WOULD JUST CALL THIS,
SLUUUUUUUTS.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: YOU WANT TO THROW ONE
IN OR NOT?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO, CHRIS,
THANKS.
>> Chris: OKAY, PLEASE.
>> HURRY UP AND TAKE THE
PHOTO SO ME AND MY BROTHER
CAN GO OUT IN THE ALLEY AND
FINGER EACH OTHER.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE POINTS TO
STEVE AGEE FOR INCESTUOUS FINGER
BANGING.
(LAUGHTER)
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> WHAT, WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
THIS YOUNG BRIT ATTEMPTING A
THUGGED OUT SELFIE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> FOR (BLEEP) SAKE.
>> Chris: WHAT IS IT, STEVE, FOR
(BLEEP) SAKE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> MIRROR, MIRROR ON THE WALL,
HERE'S A SELFIE OF ME BALL.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: JUST ONE BALL?
>> ONE BALL.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> MR. HAIRLESS POTTER.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> Chris: I SEE THE WAND
CHOOSES THE WIZARD, HARRY?
POINTS TO TOM LENNON.
>> AND POINTS TO YOU.
>> Chris: OH, THANKS.
I APPRECIATE IT, THANK YOU.
>> WOW.
WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE, EVERYTHING
DOWN FROM THE MIRROR IS GOAT
HOOVES.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: AND HE'S JUST
REALIZING IT.
(BLEEP) SAKE I'M A FAUN FROM THE
WAIST DOWN.
(LAUGHTER)
(IMITATING FLUTE)
THAT EXPLAINS THE PAN FLUTE,
DOESN'T IT THEN?
HOW ABOUT THIS PURVEYOR
OF POSITIVE ENERGY?
♪
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THIS IS BRADLEY STEVENS.
A FORMER CONTESTANT ON
@MIDNIGHT, HE DOES WARM-UP FOR
US.
STEVE, WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?
>> THE INFIDELS WILL BE SORRY
WHEN I BLOW UP THIS PARKING
GARAGE.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: APRIL?
>> THIS IS AFTER THE PERSON AT
THE DMV SAID, "I'M SORRY, SIR,
'POSITIVE ENERGY IN THE 818 I
USED TO BE A BASEBALL PITCHER'
WON'T FIT ON A LICENSE PLATE."
(LAUGHTER)
IT'S TOO MANY LETTERS.
>> Chris: THAT'S VERY INSIDE,
BUT I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
POINTS.